Now this you've seen before.
I'm just going to show this again.
This is how we can actually make
all of this wonderful stuff happen.
Here, basically you see
the multiple images,
they've been all warped together, based
on the kind of stuff we've talked about.
Again, if you notice, in this camera,
they were all taken from the same
projection point rotating
the camera this way.
And now we have all of these images.
Each one of them has been warped.
And registered on top of each other.
Here we basically kind of,
see them on top of each other,
but as I move them around, you can see
that they're all perfectly aligned.
This is the this is
the software I used to do this.
There are many different
types of softwares of course,
you can use this, use your cells for
a variety of things.